Bonjour comment allez vous? Moi ça va très bien.
Et regardez ce qu'il se passe, Trico veut des carresses
Il est la  est tous mignon depuis tout à l'heure il arrête pas de me sniffer.
EUhhhhh... Mais il va falloir avancer, souvenez-vous
On avait fait du total wipeout hein finalement la dernière fois, mon gars
on avait eu chaud au c*l et on avait atterri ici, donc on va voir où ça nous mène, tout simplement
Et je fais toujours une fixation sur le deuxième Trico (rire), qu'on a pu apercevoir mon gars...
euh je... j'm en remets pas...voilà
j'ai envie de savoir, euuh...
Ah! énigme! on commence tout de suite avec une énigme
J'ai envie de savoir qui il est, et pourquoi il est là
*musique inquiétante* Oh merde merde merde merde! oh p*tain!
Viens là viens là Trico, viens là Trico
Ah, ça me fait plaisir! ça me fait trop plaisir! A chaque épisode ça me fait plaisir de le retrouver! c'est ouf
Allez vas-y régale toi mon gars
Régale toi, j'vais te monter dessus comme ça je serai à l'abri
Ah, la queue! Hopla! C'est à moi!
Pourquoi il attaque pas?
Ah parce que y a ça qui le bloque! d'accord ok
c'est pour ça qu'il attaquera pas du coup...
Vas-y approchez vous! Ah mais ils sont bloqués
Ils peuvent pas monter
D'accord donc à mon avis j'ai le tour du truc à faire
Pour aller décrocher le truc là-haut et permettre à Trico d'aller défoncer ces vilaines armures
Bon bah écoute on va aller voir hein! Pas 36 solutions
*soupire* Oh le c*n!
On va essayer d'aller voir là-bas hein....
Mais mets pas quatre ans à te relever! Non là, il abuse!
Cet enfant abuse! Punition! Pas de PC ce soir mon gars
P*tain ils m'enchainent trop! j'arrive même pas à m'en sortir
Oh! il l'avait jamais fait ça...
C'est les gardes qui l'ouvrent cette p*tain de porte...
Mais regardez tous les sorts qu'ils envoient quoi!
Allez vas-y! mais non!
Roh p*tain...
Tiens bat*rd
Yes, je l'ai feinté
Yes, alors ça doit être quelque part par là...
Là c'est bon regardez, fallait juste atteindre cet endroit
Et là on peut escalader
Hop allez vas-y!
Dépêche toi p'tit c*n ils arrivent
'tain c'est bon! Oh la pression!
Ok ils savent pas sauter c'est un avantage
Alors, faut grimper là dessus c'est ça?
Alors attends, Trico il est là-bas, là y a le miroir...
Y a de la bouffe
Là y a rien, juste des grilles
Y a ça que je peux saisir, mais ça sert à quoi?
Ça ouvre la grille?
Oh!
Ca fait quelque chose, je sais pas trop quoi mais....!
Ah ça permet d'accéder au truc en verre... Bah voila
Là y a un rebord
Wow! Oh p*tain! Il s'est pas cassé la colonne là?
*rires* Oh merde!
Vas-y! yes!
Oh p*tain j'y croyais plus
Et donc là en bas les armures elles sont en PLS parce que j'vais pouvoir faire tomber cette merde
Cette sal*perie qui fait peur à mon Trico
Voilà
Allez Trico, c'est à toi de jouer mon gars
Rah il va les démolir
Eh bah voilà, on en parle plus
Alors dans la foulée pendant qu'il les démonte j'vais aller lui chercher
son baril de bouffe
Tiens, voilà qui va te calmer
Alors à mon avis faut aller de l'autre côté
J'peux y aller en sautant moi, tu penses?
Ouais en équilibre là...
Ca va être tendu mais y a moyen je pense
Au pire tu me rattraperas dans ta bouche comme t'as fait dans l'épisode d'avant, hein
Clac! Nous voilà sur des rails
Ok j'ai réussi!
Alors!
Oh p*tain, Trico il va être fâché
Il va être fâché, y a des choses qu'il n'aime pas
Alors, là bas je vois des marches
Donc je pense qu'il va falloir aller là bas
Mais y a ce truc là en plein milieu
Comment je suis censé accéder à ça?
Là-haut?
Y a une passerelle
Ouais ça doit être ça, ouais ok faut atteindre la passerelle là-haut
Via la chaine qui est là, via attends... non non mais c'est un délire là
Donc à mon avis faut aller là-dessus déjà
Mais là-dessus c'est trop loin je peux pas y aller seul
Trico faut que tu viennes
Tu peux venir ou pas?
Qu'est-ce qu'il fout?
30 minutes de galère plus tard car Squeezie est très très c*n
Ok de retour sur les rails, p*tain ça a été très compliqué
J'vais pouvoir aller... en fait je suis hyper c*n...
Fallait juste aller là
Et lui ouvrir
Tout bêtement
Allez on prend, on rabaisse
*bruitage de qualité par Squeezie*
Wah y a un trou!
Oh p*tain, j'ai failli mourir
Maintenant tu prends ta bouffe avant
Mange le et viens
yeah...
Très très bien, allez c'est parti
Bon il va me suivre naturellement, c'est un pot de colle Trico, hein, c'est un animal très fidèle
Donc je pense qu'il va me suivre...
Pff! j'avais des doutes sur sa fidélité là
Nous voici donc dans ce nouvel endroit
Euh donc je pense que de base, à mon avis, le truc à faire ce sera de monter là haut
et de faire un saut sur la cage
Mais oui mon grand, il est grand là
Il est loin...
Tu vas devoir te mettre debout contre ça
Ouais vas-y tu l'as vu
yeah!
En plus y a de la bouffe tu vois
J'vais pouvoir te régaler
Euuuh (cri de peur)
pourquoi il fait ça?
Pourquoi il prend des risques?
Tu veux de la bouffe? tiens mon gars
Bah fallait l'attraper en plein air!
Allez mange ça mets toi bien
Moi je vais voir comment on peut faire
Y'a pas une chaîne un.. Non faut que je saute hein.
Mais oui on va s'en sortir.
Aller faut que j'y aille.
"Cris"
Oh j'ai postillonné.
Ok, la grille, logiquement on peut s'a...ccrocher, ouhh putain il me fait peur.
Ce gamin me terrifie mon gars, dans ses mouv'
J'ai peur qu'il tombe.
Heuuuuuu, ensuite une fois qu'on est là
Y'a une chaîne qui est là
qui va surement se balancer
"Cris"
ça me,
Ca fait peur de ouf mec
Allez foire pas steuplaît
C'est bon!
Ok la chaîne d'en face... hiii !
Oh c'était limite !
Là on va descendre, oh putain là va y avoir un truc d'équilibre à gérer
Ca va être l'enfer, ça va être l'enfer
Si j'me foire on est mort
C'est simple si j'me foire on meurt
Ok ! Go !
*cris strident*
*cris de soulagement*
J'y arrive pas à avoir la notion des distances aujourd'hui j'ai peur à chaque fois
Il est où Trico il est là-bas il va bien ?
Ok il me regarde, il est miignon mais il est mignon !
On le dira jamais assez
allez on va faire tomber l'objet et tu seras libéré délivré
Alors on attérit là ok
Faut aller de l'autre côté je suppose
Hop là ya des morceaux
on peut s'y prendre
En vrai il est trop fort en escalade ce gamin c'est un truc de malade
clairement il a pratiqué
Ah il peut se mettre debout dessus ? Ah bah ça facilite grandement les choses
*rire nerveux*
YAVAIT UN TROU !
Du coup faut se servir du trou pour passer de l'autre côté en fait
et bah merci euuh à la mort de nous avoir permis de découvrir ça
J'ai peur de ouf
Ok euuuh... ok je vois
ok suspends toi
Hop là, on va se mettre debout
là-dessus et accédez à l'autre ok
Putain Trico il est pas serein mon gars, il est tellement pas serein
Il est encore moins serein que nous quand on le voit se battre quoi
Ok et là je vais repasser de l'autre côté dans le trou... putain j'avais pas vu le trou
du tout juste avant
je suis vraiment pas en forme aujourd'hui p*tain
Chui nul ou quoi ?
Et là on arrive en haut
et on va pouvoir
Faut le détacher ?
Attend doit y avoir un délire avec le mécanisme derrière, ça là
J'vais aller dessus ça va faire contre-poids ou un truc du genre, c'est ça ?
Euh moi j'pense qu'y faut sauter en face, voilà j'ai pas trop réfléchi à cette option
Donc on va voir tout de suite si ça marche
P*tain c'est chaud ! Là on va jouer
l'équilibriste mon gars... mais ça va l'faire
on monte hop on atteint le premier, oh p*tain c'est chaud par contre
On est tellement haut mec, on a jamais été aussi haut et loin d'un bord en fait c'est ça
qui est stressant
Trico aussi il est en PLS totale
On continue d'escalader figurez vous
c'est incroyable
je pense qu'on en arrive là et d'ici on va pouvoir décrocher le truc
à mon avis, ouais ouais regardez on va pouvoir le pousser
Mais ça va faire un bordel monstre !
Nan mais mec c'est sûr et certain, on va tomber
Y a pas de...
Ah non c'est bon euuh...
Non c'est bon (x3) ça change pas l'équilibre du truc
ok on est bon
Putain on casse tout mon gars !
Et là il me rejoint comment Trico ?
C'est ça la question
Ah ya des piliers ok il va aller sur les piliers
Ya un ptit pilier là, voi...
Ah il fait le grand saut direct !
Je suis là mon amour !!
Oh ! *rire*
Oh c'est bien fait putain  je croyais vraiment que j'mettais juste foiré
Merci mon grand j'adore ta queue
*rire* il est mignon il me regarde, il regarde sa queue tranquillement
Bon va falloir que tu te tournes et qu'on aille de l'autre côté mon gars
Voiiilà !  et là tu sautes, là tu jump
Oh putain ah mais heureusement qu'il s'est musclé les... la poigne cet enfant
Yeeeees !
ok
Euuuh là haut tu peux monter ouais encore un dernier tu peux le faire je le sais
Fais pas genre !
Yeeeees !
Ah ya un miroir !
alors attends bouge pas j'avais oublié ta petite phobie
Vas-y saute, voiilà parfait !
C'est pas très stable... si ça va
alors ce truc on l'prend
et on le pousse
Attends j'ai peur de partir avec, j'ai vraiment peur de partir avec
allez dégage ça dégage
Hop la !
Vas-y viens !
Ah faut que j'dégage les bouts de verre comme ça aussi c'est ça ?
Ah il me fait peur putain Trico fait pas ça mon gars
Oh nan ça se pète la gueule ?
Va falloir qu'on réagisse vite !
Ok chui sur toi vas-y, oh putain c'était rapide mon gars
Trico jte laisse gérer mec moi j'peux plus là je...
j'ai pas les capacités pour gerer ça !
ok on est bien, on est bien, on est bien...
on est bien
Et ben mec va falloir atteindre le pont hein
Tu sais qu'on a pas le choix
J'pars discrètement du cu* de Trico
Ya des trucs pour descendre... si si j'pense que c'est pas là pour rien
Ils auraient pas mis ça là
Ah ça queue m'amène pile poil là où il faut *rire*
ouais bouge pas trop par contre sinon j'vais vraiment me foirer et tomber dans le vide
Ok on est bon !
donc la en suite j'remonte par là
Mais nan ! Si c'est bon
J'remonte par là et il faut... y faut que j'atteigne l'autre côté moi
même ? et que j'le motive avec de la bouffe
Tu vas pas faire ton sauvageon euh Trico
Chui sûr que c'est ça en plus
On prend des risques mais j'pense vraiment qu'il va falloir qu'on aille
près d'un câble pour traverser en fait
c'est sûr
et maintenant qu'on est là
Ok on peut monter à gauche là où ya de l'herbe, on sait que l'herbe c'est bon signe en plus
et on atteint une petite...
cinématique
j'arrive j'arrive p*tain il doit pas être confort sur son pilier...
J'adore cette langue, j'ai fait une grosse connerie en disant que c'était en japonais
Quand la voix off parlait j'avais l'impression vraiment que c'était du japonais
ce qui prouve que je ....
ne parle pas du tout japonais du coup *rire*
Nan en fait c'est une langue créée pour le jeu c'est ouf
ils font un vrai travail de recherche et il créent une p*tain de langue
Vas-y saute
Bon il veut pas sauter
Voilà
Alors on arrive du coup dans nouvel endroit on fait le tour par l'intérieur c'est ça
J'espère qu'y aura pas d'armures mec...
bien sûr c'est quand je dis ça qu'il y en a une
Va falloir aller très vite mec ya pas de secret, va falloir aller très très vite c'est tout
QUOI ?!
Mais elle va s'faire engueuler par son boss l'armure elles sont pas censées
me buter *rire*
voilà hop j'ai fait une 'tite esquive, putain le truc il m'a poussé dans l'vide
Chui choqué mon gars, normalement il te prend et il t'emmène là dans leur vieux cabanon
Et là il te pousse dans le vide calmement
faut que je fasse quoi avec ça ? ah faut qu'j'aille là-bas au milieu ok
yolo
ok j'ai réussi
Alors et au milieu qu'est-ce qu'on a ? Un levier parfait !
qui va ouvrir la grille qu'il y avait là haut je suppose
voilà même lui il se dit et merde il a trouvé il est pas con
allez c'est parti
on y retourne pour un tour
Va falloir que j'esquive, attention pro esquive
Hop là pffff
il m'a fait peur
Alors va falloir faire très vite parce qu'il va continuer de me suivre le c*n
Ooooh !
WTF ?!
J'fais quoi là ? ah p*tain j'vais tomber
ok je redescends j'sais même pas où je vais attérir
Fallait que j'monte bah j'avais une chance sur deux
je pense qu'on va monter
aller vite vite, me dit pas qu'il y a une grille, nan ah y'a porte des gardiens
p*tain
p*tain encore un gardien
C'est chaud, ah du coup ya une porte
ouais là s'il m'attrape en gros j'aurais pas le temps de me libérer il me foutra dans la porte
ok... oh nan t'es sérieux ?!
Yolo j'passe
Faut qu'j'aille en bas là vite vite, mec j'fais le saut de l'ange j'men bats les couilles en mode
assasin's creed b*tch !
Ah, ça c'est fais
ok 2eme porte qui s'ouvre
J'espère qu'y aura pas encore plus d'armures derrière
On est ti-par ! (parti)
Hop
oh p*tain ils sont là
J'crois qu'il y en a un qu'est resté en haut.. ah non c'est bon
et bah écoute j'peux me barrer tranquillement
Ils m'envoient des sorts c'est vraiment des p*tes
Vas-y fonce n'ait pas peur, c'est pas le moment d'avoir peur mon gars
Allez vas-y ! ils te suivent
Ya Trico qu'est pas loin, il est où ? ok il doit être en dessous de moi
c'est comme ça qu'on accède à l'autre côté d'accord, j'pensais que c'était par un câble, et ben non !
ok j'ai compris j'ai compris je vais pas
chercher trop loin
P*tain c'est tendu là
Trico qui est juste en dessous... AH il se prend des javelots ! MAIS NON !
le temps que je mets à aller de l'autre côté il se prend des javelots putain !
NAN ! Oh non les p*tain
p*tain j'espère qu'ils vont pas le tuer (x2)
Vite, vite, vite !
Aller !
Allez on y va
Allez vas-y on y va
Non !
J'ai besoin de ton aide Trico (x2)
J'ai besoin de ton aide, si tu viens pas je meurs
J'te retire les pieux vas-y tu passes (x4)
Vas-y j'te retire les pieux, j'pense qu'il a du mal parce qu'il a mal
Faut que j'retire les pieux
ok ils sont où les autres ?
t'en as encore un là
Vas-y c'est bon je t'ai tout retiré,
Tricooo
J'arrive mon grand j'vais aller de l'autre côté
et j'vais t'aider j'vais l'ouvrir de l'autre côté moi j'peux y aler
j'y vais j'y vais j'y vais j'y vais j'y
vais j'pensais qu'il fallait te retirer les pieux
mais nan c'est juste que tu peux pas en fait
Ya pas un levier un truc là
Le levier il est juste là ! mec il est caché
j'avais pas vu putain, en même temps j'panique
mon gars j'vois Trico pas bien chui pas bien moi
Aller vas-y tu viens
Maintenant tu peux venir, allez on est
libérés
On continue
Pfiou c'est chaud mec hein
On a failli perdre Trico
Sur ce coup on a vraiment failli perdre Trico mon gars, c'est chaud
Est-ce qu'on va retrouver le miroir ?
Je me demande.Mais ça va Trico, tu t'en es remis mon gars.
Il y a un levier ici
C'est un truc à tirer ça
Tu m'étonnes vu comment il a du forcer sur ses bras
Bah attends mec, je peux totalement passer par là. Gros boloss. Bah voilà, énorme boloss
Et là derrière y'aura peut-être de la bouffe...
...ou des gardes
On sait pas encore. On va bien trouver de la bouffe ici.
Oh merde !
J'étais destiné à tomber, on va pas se mentir
Et les papillons, j'ai raté de la bouffe?
Y'a des papillons là
Ahhh voilà !
Très bien ! Ah non mais attends je suis carrément enseveli là
comment je fais
Et si enfaite je monte là et j’envoie là-bas le truc
Bah voilà...AH non mais on n'a pas de chance là !
N'importe quoi mais apprends à viser
Ah il était beau celui... MAIS NON
Mais comment...?
OUIIII...NOOON
Tu te coinces
Putain
P*tain le c*n
Mais p*tain
Oui ! La caméra avait dit "bon bah je rage-quit, ça me saoule, c'est bon t'es lancé".
Enfin mon gars, enfin...C'est la fiesta loca, on va le récupérer là
Tombe pas tombe pas, c'est bon. Oh putain j'ai tellement peur qu'il tombe
et là logiquement on peut se barrer
et on l'a bien mérité me direz-vous
j'approuve ! j'arrive Trico
Trico a eu le temps de mourir 200 fois de faim mon gars... Ah putain je suis désolé mec
Ah il a vu la bouffe, il a l'oeil de l'animal qui a vu la bouffe. Tiens mon pote
Hop là ! ça fait du bien
Ahhh ça se porte bien d'un coup
on est mieux là
et on se lève carrément
C'est parfait mon Trico
Ah il saute de joie, il est content. Aller on va pouvoir continuer mon gars
Donc ce truc là j'pense qu'on peut le... ah bah non ça bougeait pas tout à l'heure
pourquoi ça bougerait maintenant
Ah ok ! non c'est parce que y'en avait 2 qu'étaient collés
attention à pas mourir écrasé par un chariot quand même
C'est bon y est ! Qu'est-ce que ça ouvre ça ?
Ah il va me montrer j'pense
Ah ça ouvre la porte qu'est là-bas
Trico il vient du coup?
Ah il le pousse ok super
merci Trico ! nous voilà
maintenant enfermés tous les deux ici
Mais qu'est-ce qu'on fout ? Ah si peut-être à gauche là attendez
Peut-être qu'ici... c'est forcément par là y a qu'un
chemin
c'est forcément par la... oh ! ooooh
D'accord lampe torche ! Tes yeux font des lampes torches nickel !
Bah tu vas venir mon gars et tu vas m'éclairer
et clairement à cet endroit
qu'est-ce qu'on a ?
Vas-y avance continue (x3)
Tu m'indiques un chemin là... ouais par là
Là haut y a un truc par contre je suppose
Doit y avoir un truc... ah ouais ! Tout là haut mec, ok
Vas-y let's go !
Yeah ! Ah oui d'accord t'as carrément fait plus que te mettre debout
On est bien là ! Là il faut sortir hein
ya pas 36 solutions
ok vas-y
Ouaaiis
merci l'biceps !
et c'est là que tu m'abandonnes parce qu'y a un miroir et que tu te chies dessus c'est ça ?
Qu'est-ce que j'peux faire ici ?
Non ! (on entend le 2e Trico au loin)
Non ! La 2eme bête ?
Y avait le bruit de la 2eme bête mec ! Ah il l'a vu il a vu le saut à faire
Il l'a vu tout seul
Il est très malin, vas-y mon grand
WOUHOU
J'te jure que si le 2eme Trico c'est une meuf, en faisant ça tu l'as séduit
Elle est toute émue
Ok à droite maintenant, vas-y t'as compris tout seul...
A mon avis il faut que je...
ok parfait ! Oh **tain j'y suis allé au
culot mon gars je m'attendais pas à un...
résultat si euuh
Bon cette fois j'y vais en mode prudence, prudence extrême
mais c'est vraiment ça à mon avis il faut vraiment marcher en équilibre sur le truc
parre qu'en plus regardez ya de l'herbe là bas pour s'accrocher et monter !
Il a l'oeil hein ! Hop là, oh putain !
On va y aller tout doux, tout à l'heure j'ai fait le bourrin mais faut vraiment y aller tout j'pense
tout doux voilà comme ça on part de la passerelle
et on est en équilibre.. on est pas bien là
on n'est pas bien p*tain
J'ai vu qu'y a un 2e truc truc en verre juste derrière en plus à aller casser
C'est bon c'est bon t'es arrivé
pourquoi tu mets la pression
Ok on est de l'autre côté
putain Trico il bloque... j'espère qu'à la fin du jeu on saura euuh...
Bah je sais pas... 'fin j'pense qu'y aura la voix off qui nous le dira mais
on saura pourquoi il a peur de ça, qui sont les mecs en armure etc quoi
On va devoir marcher sur le 2eme c'est ça ?
ouais.. ok on y va
Vous pensez qu'y a des gens qui vont se faire le même tatouage du coup ?
Moi perso celui là j'lai fait parce que j'ai vu que le ptit garçon de ...
The Last Guardian avait un crabe tatoué sur... c'est trop long
Trico il doit être en PLS là mon gars
Oh il s'en bat les couilles ! Ouais bah ouais tu reviens pour être le proche de moi à chaque fois
ok bah écoutez on est en train d'atteindre le sommet
de la... putain c'est
vachement haut mon gars ! Hop ok
Encore un ?! Ah oui mais là c'est celui qui nous mène directement au...
à l'élément perturbateur alors vas-y
j'vais pousser, putain mais
faut vraiment, franchement si tu battais ta peur Trico, putain tu saignes de partout mon pauvre
les javelots tout à l'heure ils t'ont abîmé
si tu battais un petit peu ta peur tu nous ferais gagner tellement de temps
Mais tellement Trico
et surtout tu nous ferais prendre tellement moins de risques
à chaque fois j'ai peur que tout se pète la
gueule en...
Voilà voilà quand je parle de risque, tu vois, c'est exactement de ça que je parle
Ouais c'est ça
Voilà
C'est partiii
hop là, sur le museau direct, putain beau gosse Trico là ce que tu nous fais
Voilà le petit rebord là il est pour toi tu l'as vu
Yeah, Au top
Y'a des marches à faire
Papapa, pour aller péter un autre miroir je crois que j'ai vu
déjà sur toi, monte le plus que tu peux
fais-moi kiffer
ok nickel
ouah! ça va, ça va, ça va
Et là, y'a le miroir qui va le bloquer
Ah bah je vais y aller en mode rebord
AH oui bah oui laisse-moi faire de toute manière c'est toujours moi qui m'y colle on a compris
Bon j'avoue les armures c'est toi qui t'y colle
Allez vas-y celui-la il va être facile à péter en plus let's go !
Eh ouais mon gars
c'est ça d'avoir un corps d'enfant
Dans la vraie vie j'peux faire pareil
Allez on y va, ça dégage
Heuuu vite vite y'a un blème
Oh sa mère, oh sa mère, Trico
Trico
Aide-moi
Tu vois bien que je peux rien faire, aide-moi je vais tomber Trico
Qu'est-ce qu'il fout ?
Heu ok d'accord
Ah il va en bas pour me réceptionner, OK
Faut que j'me lâche, OK
OH j'pensais pas ça possible que ça foire
Allez t'es super proche là, vas-y.
Ah cette fois il m'a eu
Ah putain
on était pas loin de la mort là quand même Trico
Ça va de jouer avec notre coeur comme ça
Aaaah putain
OK on s'en est sorti
toujours la queue qui est là pour nous
sauver on aime cette queue
on l'apprécie
on lui fait des bisous *rires*
Y'a plus le miroir tu nous fais kiffer maintenant Trico
vas-y saute cette fois je suis accroché mon pote
Voilà
accroche-toi, toi enfant p*tain t'as vu ce que tu t'es mangé déjà tout à l'heure
Fallait que ça arrive de toute manière, fallait que ça arrive
OK c'est bon
Oh putain, tu me fais peur, heureusement que tu as de la force dans les pattes avant mec
OUI !!
Yes, allez encore un peu de chemin et on est bon
allez, va falloir accéder à une grille là-bas c'est ça je suppose
Ouais
OKAY
Oh putain, oh putain  j'te laisse gérer mec
Eh ça m'a fait tellement mal au coeur de voir Trico tomber comme ça mec
Et bah voilà les amis c'est déja la fin de cette quatrième vidéo sur The Last Guardian
j'espère quelle vous a plu ainsi que toutes les autres n'hésitez pas à l'aimer si c'est le cas, ça me fera très plaisir
j'pense qu'on en sera plus très rapidement j'ai hâte du prochain épisode
Là je vais à la boulangerie et je tourne le prochain c'est obligé
Ah bah j'suis impatient
allez à très vite dans une prochaine vidéo, merci d'avoir regardé, portez-vous bien
ciao  tout le monde
PEACE